كما قلت العراقيون يعاونون كثيرا على
المساهمه القطريه في هذا الموضوع وانها
ستعطي دفعه حقيقيه لتنفيذ هذا المشروع ضمن
العطر الزمنيه التي حددتها الحكومه
العراقيه هذا المشروع على ثلاث مراحل
تنتهي المرحله الاولى منه في العام 2018
والمرحله الثانيه في عام
2038 والمرحله الثالثه والاخيره تنتهي في
العام 2050 هذه واحده وليست فقط هذه كل ما
سيتم الحديث عنه هذه واحده من العدنان من
النقاط التي سيتم بحثها والحديث على عنها
اليوم وبالتالي توقيع هذه المذكرات التي
يعتقد العراق كثيرا انها ستساهم كثيرا في
تعزيز العلاقه بين البلدين
مكتبنا وليد ابراهيم لوصول امير دوله قطر
الشيخ تميم بن حمد الثاني واستقبال محمد
شياع السوداني له في المطار بغداد الدولي
وهذه زياره تاتي بتلبيه لدعوه محمد شياع
السوداني ورئيس الوز راء العراقي وتعد اول
زياره للقائد عربي للعراق في ظل حكومه
محمد السوداني وكما ذكر والد ابراهيم
يتوقع ان يكون هناك توقيع لنوايا للتعاون
الشامل كما باتت تعرف الان في العراق